un bon soir au la mosquée dino merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
le bilan qui continue a évidemment
augmenté en italie
quelle est la situation sur place
bonjour une plutôt bon soir j'ai
effectivement les derniers chiffres et
n'est qu'une couverture nationale
aussi l'association aujourd'hui nous
avons 23 mille cas confirmés est de 349
morts c'est à dire qu'en une journée
nous avons eu 3 149 morts
supplémentaires mais on observe une
tendance et défendant très légère nous
sommes là une phase difficile et j'ai
entendu le discours de riches et m'a
pris au pays et j'apprécie le fait de
décider de d'adopter des mesures
strictes comme en italie situation ses
frisettes difficile cet hiver véritable
aide
macron a bien utilisé le nom ne pourra
noter que cette année les liens que si
je l'étais européen adopte les mesures
strictes les amis de contre cet ennemi
invisible au repos la jeunesse kabyle on
n'a pas encore évidemment
l'explication de texte dans les détails
du gouvernement qui va s'atteler à le
faire dès demain
et pour le moment selon notre
compréhension et emmanuel macron a
écarté un confinement total à
l'italienne parce qu'il me semble que
vous vous ne pouvez vraiment pas sortir
de chez vous sous peine d'amendé il
appelle à limiter les déplacements il
proscrit les déplacements dans les
quinze jours seulement mais les français
ne semblent pas être en confinement
total chez eux c'est peut-être une
petite nuance quand même importante non
ya tout un tas
il est important pourtant de rester chez
soi des capteurs et des scientifiques
ont été très clairs là-dessus et rester
à la maison et le seul moyen pour à
ralentir pu éviter la propagation du
virus à mais je sais la seule oui
l'usure oui que nous ayons oui c'est
inouï weekly nous restons chez nous
devons pas quitter le domicile sans vie
sont valides qu'il s'agissait d'aller
travailler
mais jeter de la nourriture de
médicaments
si notre pays est complètement
verrouillé
[Musique]
nous ne connaissons pas le résultat de
cette mesure
oui oui non mais nous savons que c'est
le seul moyen d'influencer la situation
de lutter contre ce virus
donc la vie non la situation est très
préoccupante notamment dans le nord
car c'est là qu'est l'épicentre de la
fin des mises au sud du pays ue
il y a des cas là il y avait très peu de
cas en tout cas jusqu'à ce que beaucoup
de personnes
de cinquante mille personnes se
déplacent du nord vers le sud pour
retrouver la famille semaines après
cette grande de transhumance mon amour
ce déplacement massif
le nombre des cas a commencé à augmenter
cela montre bien l'importance de ce
confinement
il faut suivre les règles du
gouvernement
c'est à 5 ou l'accepter car c'est une
mesure d éclater si elle dit hindi
merci par l'apa me pardonnez moi de vous
de vous couper de la sorte il ya un mur
un invité espagnol également qui attend
depuis un petit moment on va devoir le
prendre aussi en direct merci en tout
cas pas au la mousse cardinaux d'avoir
été avec nous en direct on a bien
compris en tout cas la situation en
italie merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france merci